[Music]
aws lambda is relatively new and it
isn't coming up on the exam much at the
moment but it will do in the future so
it's good to have an overview of what it
does
so aws lambda lets you run code without
provisioning or managing servers
so you only pay for the compute time
that you consume and there's no charge
when your code isn't running
so the best way to explain it would be
rather than having an ec2 instance that
you have sat around that occasionally
runs some code
aws lambda just runs the code and aws
manages everything else for you
so how this works would be firstly you
upload your code to aws lambda
and then you set up your code to trigger
from other aws services or endpoints
so it may be that a file arrives in an
s3 bucket which triggers lambda to do
something
when the trigger happens lambda runs
your code using only the compute
resources needed
and then it will shut down again
straight away so you're paying just for
the compute time you use
there are some huge benefits to using
aws lambda firstly there's no servers to
manage
aws lambda automatically runs your code
without requiring you to provision or
manage servers you just write the code
and upload it
lander continuously scales your
application by running the code in
response to each trigger
so if you have hundreds of thousands of
triggers lambda will automatically scale
precisely with the size of your workload
and also with lambda
you're only charged for every 100
milliseconds your code executes and the
number of times your code is triggered
and you pay nothing when the code isn't
running
let's take a look at some case studies
to show you how lambda is used in the
real world
the seattle times uses aws lambda to
resize images for viewing on different
devices such as desktop computers
tablets and smartphones
so here is a diagram of their process so
a photograph is taken by a user and is
uploaded to an s3 bucket as soon as it
hits the bucket lambda is triggered and
lambda runs an image resizing code to
generate web mobile and tablet-sized
versions of the image
aws elastic beanstalk is an easy-to-use
service for deploying and scaling web
applications and services
so if you have a web application written
in microsoft.net or php or java you can
just upload it to elastic beanstalk and
it will handle everything else for you
so it's kind of like lambda but this is
specifically for web applications
here are some of the benefits of elastic
beanstalk
it's the fastest and simplest way to
deploy your application on aws within
minutes your application will be ready
to use without any infrastructure or
resource configuration work on your part
to do the same with ec2 you'd manually
have to launch the ec2 instances
yourself and install the code on there
it increases your developer productivity
because elastic beanstalk provisions and
operates the infrastructure and manages
the application stack for you so you
don't have to spend the time developing
the expertise to do this
it will also keep the underlying
platform up to date with the latest
patches and updates
elastic bean automatically scales your
application up and down based on your
application's need using easily
adjustable auto scaling settings so it's
impossible to outgrow
and it gives you complete resource
control you can choose the type of
instances that it's going to be running
on that are optimal for your application
the aws command line interface is a
unified tool to manage your aws services
with just one tool to download and
configure you can control multiple aws
services from the command line and
automate them through scripts
so you can access ec2 s3 elb and tons
more things from the command line rather
than having to go through the aws
management console
amazon command line interface can be
installed on windows using an msi or on
linux and unix with pip or the bundled
installer
the amazon linux ami which we mentioned
earlier is pre-installed with aws cli
so it's used to perform multiple tasks
and some examples of this would be you
could use it to copy files to s3
you could use it to restart ec2
instances so you could write a script to
stop and start your instances
configure cloud watch alarms
or for just getting information about
your aws resources
now if you just wanted to get some
information about your running instances
there's an alternative to aws cli on
your running instances you can obtain
instance metadata and user data using a
specific url and here's the url and it's
169.254.169.254
now that's worth remembering because
that probably will come up in your exam
i know it came up in mine and in a
demonstration i'll show you how you can
use this
in this demonstration we're gonna have a
quick overview of the aws command line
interface and how it works
so i've just launched a new amazon
instance using our web server ami and
i'm just going to show you the command
line interface so this is an amazon
linux instance and that has the command
line interface pre-installed now it's
very easy to install on windows it's
just an msi that you double click
and on other linux or unix instances you
just install it
via pip
but we have it already here so
how to use it so aws
space help will give you
a description of how it works and
there's and it's quite a powerful tool
that can do pretty much most of the
things you can do through the web
console there's a whole list of services
that are available and commands you can
run now what i'm going to do is give you
a demonstration of
how to use it with amazon s3 so this is
a nice feeder into the next lesson that
we're going to be looking at so s3 is a
storage service
so through the command line
if you wanted you can create your own
amazon buckets
so we would type aws
s3 and we want to make a new bucket so
we're going to make a new amazon s3
bucket which is where we store our files
so we do make bucket s3
and then we give it a bucket name and
the bucket name has to be unique as
you'll learn later so let's call this
simply learn demo test
now that's created a bucket for us where
we can store files so why would we do
this well
we could move files in there from our
web servers so i'm in the
html folder and there's our health check
file so i could upload that file for
safe keeping to the amazon s3 bucket so
to do that i'll do aws
s3
copy
the name of the file i want to copy and
the location where i want to put it so i
can move it into the rs3 simply then
demo test bucket
hit return okay so that's uploaded so
now if i wanted to check what was in
there aws s3 so you see that's the
format says aws then the name of the
service you want to use
list
and then the name of the bucket i want
to have a look in
and there are so it's telling me that my
health check file is in there
so that's what you can use the command
line interface for so we could use this
in our bootstrapping scripts for
instance when we start up an instance we
might want to copy in some files and
some configuration values to a newly
launched server so we could say copy the
contents of the simply learn demo test
bucket onto the the web server
so another demonstration of something
you could do we could create a security
group from the command line so using the
ec2 service
we can do create
security group
then we give it a group name
which i'm going to call it
simply learn
demo
sg give it a description
demo sg
test
and then we need to give it the vpc id
it's going to reside in
so we want to put it in
our amazon vpc
our custom vpc
and the id for that is this
and we also want to give it a region
so we want to put it in usb
1.
okay so it's created a security group
for us so if we go back to the aws
management console we should be able to
see that in our list of security groups
and there it is
so we can see it there so you can create
security groups from the command line as
well
and then the other thing we talked about
in the section on cli was other ways to
get metadata from your instance and that
was used in this url so if we run the
curl command with the url it shows you a
list of things you can look at so for
example if we wanted to see the ami id
for this
instance it tells us that's our ami id
and if we go and double check that with
the aws management console
here you can see here's a list of our my
amis and that the ami id is the same so
you can get information about your
instance using that command
other things we could look at would be
the hostname for example if you wanted
to get that
and it tells you your host name there
so you can use these commands to get
stuff for your scripts or
monitoring so you don't have to have
manual intervention to get the details
or keep going back to your amazon
management console
hey want to become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simply
learn's channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here